bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau cette suite sport on
passe tout de suite au sommaire de cette
émission
il est le nouveau champion d'Europe
Walter ce samedi Le Verrier roi mais Del
Moussaoui a décroché la ceinture de
l'Union européenne face à l'Espagnol à
itornetto il reviendra sur ce titre en
exclusivité pour le 7 8 sport le 8 mars
prochain la 73e édition de Paris-Nice
partira pour la 6e fois des Yvelines un
prologue à Maurepas avant une première
étape qui se lancera de
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse ce week-end la
ville de Viroflay accueillait la
première Coupe de France de Quidditch
inspiré de la saga Harry Potter la
discipline est en pleine croissance en
France notre journaliste Yolaine Torres
l'a testé pour vous évidemment vous en
avez l'habitude l'essentiel des
résultats du week-end en fin d'émission
mais place tout d'abord à notre page
spéciale box
je le disais dans les titres il est le
nouveau champion d'Europe catégorie
Walter c'est de la boxe évidemment il
nous fait l'honneur d'être présent ce
soir sur le 7 8 sport Ahmed El Moussaoui
bonsoir à vous merci d'être là tout
d'abord j'imagine un félicitations pour
cette nouvelle ceinture c'est la
consécration pour vous la consécration
je sais pas mais c'est vrai que voilà
j'ai atteint mon objectif disons mon
petit objectif de l'année
voilà c'est pas c'était pas le plus gros
combat enfin j'espère de même de ma
carrière mais c'est vrai que c'est un
très bon départ pour moi c'est une étape
supplémentaire évidemment dans votre
progression vous avez été par le passé
champion de France et puis on sait que
vous avez beaucoup d'ambition quand on
avait suivi votre préparation il y a
quelques jours qu'un jour exactement
j'avais senti déjà une grande confiance
avant ce combat bah ça s'est vérifié
samedi soir dans les Ardennes c'est vrai
que dans ce genre de combat je pense
qu'il faut être faute sur un faut être
confiant et minimum parce que vous savez
c'est un sport difficile et c'est
beaucoup mental donc c'est c'est dans
ces moments là qu'il faut être fort et
je pense qu'il faut être confiant et je
pense c'est ce que ce qu'a fait aussi le
petit truc qui a aussi déclenché la
victoire parce que fallait être présent
ouais vous gagnez au point à l'unanimité
des juges 117 110 115 111 et 114 112 ça
a été un combat difficile quand même
âpre
qu'on va difficile je dirais pas ça mais
c'est vrai que tu m'as donné un petit
peu de fil à retode c'était pas le
combat le plus dur de ma carrière
c'était peut-être le plus long parce que
c'était mon premier 12 drone mais
disons que j'ai bien géré le combat je
suis très satisfait de mon combat parce
que j'ai réussi à gérer deux secondes
pour un pour une première c'est pas mal
j'ai justement comment vous avez
appréhendé cette nouveauté entre
guillemets sur le ring mais c'est vrai
que au moment donné je suis arrivé au
bout du combat et un moment donné je me
suis dit c'est vrai que c'est long 2
secondes c'est très long je suis arrivé
au 7e round
je me posais des questions et c'est là
qu'il fallait ou mentalement les deux
les deux et c'est là qu'il fallait être
fort mentalement
peut-être que le moment clé de ce combat
ça se passe au quatrième round là où
vous vous mettez à terre justement étant
yéto avec une superbe une superbe droite
c'est à partir de là où vous avez senti
que vous preniez un peu plus l'ascendant
ouais c'est vrai que ce passage là
à ce moment-là d'ailleurs j'ai boxé
décontracté et je pense que c'est ça qui
a fait la différence aussi la preuve
l'habitude peut-être que ça s'attendait
à un autre schéma tactique de ma part
bon après j'étais relâché le coup le le
chaos est venu tout seul je l'ai pas
cherché et c'est vrai que ça a pris ça a
joué ça a joué gros dans le combat parce
que il a eu du mal à revenir et ça fait
une grosse différence et ça m'a mis plus
en confiance
à se remettre un petit peu vraiment en
situation
cette victoire elle prouve un petit peu
votre progression parce que on s'était
vu il y a un an avant votre titre
national ce titre de champion de France
où la balle monte de la boxe attendait
beaucoup de vous pour un premier titre
et là vous vous êtes entouré il y a
votre agent votre préparateur physique
un entraîneur spécial box c'est tous ces
ingrédients qui font qu'aujourd'hui vous
êtes champion d'Europe
disons que moi j'ai toujours c'est vrai
qu'il faut s'entourer des meilleurs pour
être le meilleur donc c'est c'est ce que
je fais et par contre
je vais pas brûler les étapes donc je
vais doucement là c'est une première
étape de fait et la suite arrive très
prochainement justement faut le dire
faut le rappeler vous avez à peine 25
ans donc il y a encore de belles années
sur le ring 24 exactement entre deux
champions d'Europe Yann notre consultant
cyclisme qui est présent ce soir
peut-être une question à Ahmed ou une
réaction par rapport à ce titre c'est
par rapport à la question que vous allez
vous allez poser c'est vrai que il a
remarqué qu'il a fait il faut s'entourer
des meilleurs pour pour être le meilleur
et donc bah je pense que là tu as tout
compris et continue dans ce sens là et
tu arriveras à aller chercher je pense
que tu cherches derrière t'en parles pas
mais ça viendra justement beaucoup les
prochaines étapes quelles sont-elles un
titre Intercontinental par exemple il y
a déjà des idées
je pense qu'on va faire une défense de
titre pour commencer c'est bien sort de
se remettre encore faire un bon petit
doudoune
enfin partir sur un 12-room depuis
pourquoi pas une ceinture
intercontinentale c'est vrai et pour
pouvoir
essayer d'atteindre moins le Top 20
mondial là je suis classé j'ai fait un
bon là de au moins ça presque 50 places
j'étais 100e là je suis 57e à 24 ans en
plus on est peut-être 6 ou 7 à avoir
moins de 24 ans dans le top 50 donc je
suis
merci beaucoup
ahmedisport on suivra évidemment ces
prochaines étapes j'imagine quelques
jours de repos là après ce combat avant
de repartir à l'entraînement c'est vrai
que 12 secondes c'est long et ça laisse
des petites séquelles quand même donc je
me repose mais ça va j'ai pas pris de
coups qui m'ont touché donc ça va à
votre visage ça va à peu près merci
beaucoup Ahmed à très bientôt on
enchaîne avec le cyclisme
le 8 mars prochain je le disais dans les
titres de cette émission la 73e édition
de Paris Nice partira une nouvelle fois
la sixième exactement des Yvelines un
prologue à Maurepas avant une première
étape qui se lancera de
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse et l'audimoine
pour les images
entre Paris Nice et les Yvelines
l'histoire d'amour ne s'arrête plus les
8 et 9 mars prochain la Course au Soleil
s'élancera pour la sixième fois du
département
c'est indissociable de la mémoire et de
la légende de Jacques cantine les
grandes années du Grand Prix des nations
donc du Grand Prix des nations dans les
années 50 jusqu'au championnat du monde
sur piste en février prochain et à Paris
Nice l'année prochaine comme C5
dernières années et comme encore au mois
de d'autres années ça veut bien dire
quelque chose puis bien sûr tout dans
les Yvelines ce lien évident réel
concret entre la pratique de la
bicyclette au quotidien et le cyclisme
des champions contrairement à 2014 un
prologue de 6 km 700 lancera la course à
travers la ville de Maurepas les
coureurs devraient s'élancer du parc du
bout des clos en passant par la rue de
la Tour pour terminer du côté du
boulevard Michel Miserey c'est une
fierté puis je pense que je ne pouvais
pas espérer mieux en tout cas en début
de mandat d'accueillir cette treizième
édition du Paris-Nice se prologue parce
que voilà
on va démarrer le dimanche 8 mars pour
ce qui concerne la course mais pour ce
qui concerne l'animation dans la ville
ça va commencer déjà dès le samedi donc
on va en profiter vraiment pour faire
rayonner la ville de Maurepas au
lendemain du prologue la première étape
partira de Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse pour
une destination encore inconnue le
peloton devrait toutefois se diriger
vers le Loir-et-Cher pour l'instant
impossible de connaître le lieu
d'arrivée exacte des coureurs même si on
a essayé c'était peut-être il ira jusque
dans le Loir-et-Cher donc voilà donc on
va utiliser on va emprunter sur ces sur
ces routes la première partie c'est les
routes de Paris Tours quand Paris tour
partait de Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines on
aura une difficulté tout de suite après
le départ donc à la sortie de Chevreuse
en direction de Cernay-la-Ville donc une
difficulté la seule difficulté de cette
étape qui va donner des points pour le
classement du meilleur grimpeurs avec
des étapes très exposées au vent les
favoris devront être vigilants dès les
premiers kilomètres pour le reste du
tracé il faudra attendre le 3 février
prochain et la présentation officielle
de 73e édition et vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure évidemment notre consultant
cyclisme Yann dujariet présent sur le
plateau du 7 8 sport ce soir rebonsoir
Yann une petite réaction déjà avec ce
Paris-Nice donc version 2015 qui va
partir une nouvelle fois des Yvelines ça
prouve que les Yvelines sont la Mecque
du cyclisme français en quelque sorte
c'est votre avis
et une autre Vélodrome ben oui on va
commencer à faire partie quoi donc c'est
vrai que ce serait bien que ça perdure
et puis on a aussi le départ de on en
parlera ce temps plus tard dans la
saison mais on a su le départ de Paris
Brest Paris tout le temps de 50 ans en
Yvelines donc c'est vrai que là c'est
des Yvelines terre de vélo dans
l'Île-de-France et 6e départ donc de ce
Paradise dans le département le cyclisme
c'est quand même sur route c'est quand
même un spectacle gratuit l'un des seuls
spectacles sportifs gratuits c'est une
occasion j'imagine imaginer pour tous
les imaginable pardon pour tous les
passionnés du département de voir tous
ces champions on adore on adore pouvoir
aller côtoyer les cyclistes les
cyclistes professionnels d'aller voir
leur matériel parce que c'est un sport
de de ouais ou le matériel a une vraie
importance et donc c'est vrai que c'est
des choses qui sont toujours agréables
et puis aussi de pouvoir aller les de
pouvoir aller se comparer parce que
quand on sait qu'ils ont mis temps de
temps pour grimper 17 tournants il y a
deux ou trois ans quand ils ont fait par
une liste bah on peut voir que alors la
même condition puisque la route est
fermée ils peuvent la prendre
différemment mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours toujours très agréable de
pouvoir de pouvoir se comparer et
justement en parlant de champion lors de
cette conférence de presse la semaine
dernière de pour ce départ donc de Paris
Nice 2015 Bernard Hinault était présent
vous le savez c'est ce vin quintuple
vainqueur du Tour de France il ne s'est
jamais imposé sur la course au soleil
car en fin de compte cette course à
étape lançait plutôt ça saison en vue du
Tour de France on l'écoute
j'ai fait une fois deuxième derrière
Thomann mais c'était pas la course pour
moi qui était la priorité prioritaire
parce que on est au mois de mars et moi
la priorité c'est à partir du mois
d'avril au mois de mai c'était de monter
en puissance pour arriver au départ du
tour dans de bonnes conditions
et on revient à l'actualité un petit peu
plus locale et des clubs locaux le Vélo
Club justement d'Élancourt
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines a lancé sa
nouvelle saison ce week-end et il
continue son sa vague de dynamisme ce
samedi après-midi le vaisseau Sky a
présenté son nouveau maillot vous le
voyez avec des nouvelles couleurs
justement Yann Le Club d'Élancourt 50
ans Yvelines a lancé une section piste
depuis l'ouverture du Vélodrome il y a
une marraine qui s'appelle Isabelle
Gautron qu'on connaît bien dans la piste
un multiple championne de France ça
insuffle quelque chose dans les clubs
locaux ce vélo c'est un superbe outil on
en a parlé plusieurs fois déjà depuis
depuis que je viens vous voir c'est
c'est ça nous change notre quotidien
d'aller faire un entraînement de
dimanche matin on va aller de Chevreuse
quand il fait 2 degrés voire moins là
vous allez rouler au Vélodrome vous
enfin c'est pas du tout pareil c'est
c'est génial et puis aussi pareil
d'avoir la chance de pouvoir rencontrer
François Pervis de pouvoir rencontrer
Grégory Baugé tous ces tous ces
champions parce qu'on les voit quand on
quand on y est il nous encadre aussi
maintenant sur les sur les séances aussi
bien le soir que que le matin
d'avoir des conseils moi j'ai progressé
sur sur le 200m dernièrement grâce à
grâce au conseil de
je retrouve plus son nom
et puis Benjamin mais après à faire du
sur place la semaine dernière donc c'est
c'est que du bonheur ouais non non c'est
c'est génial permanent qui permet
évidemment de progresser les sections
pistes se créer un petit peu partout là
dans les clubs on sait qu'il y avait les
cas il y a aussi donc ce club
d'Élancourt 50 ans Yvelines c'est
presque obligatoire pour les clubs on va
dire locaux et Linois de se lancer dans
la piste mais la piste c'est l'école de
vélo l'école du vélo Marca Wendy je sais
passer par la piste
beaucoup de grands champions
passe par la piste commence par la piste
et ils étaient champions du monde tous
les deux de la course à l'américaine
donc voilà c'est il faut que les gens
comprennent qu'on peut être bon surpris
c'est qu'on sera très bon sur route par
la suite Brian Coquard on est là à la
preuve il a quand même fait une médaille
de médaille d'argent championnat de aux
Jeux olympiques et il y a une belle une
belle carrière qui lui est ouverte
maintenant sur sur la route donc il faut
que les jeunes se mettent à la piste il
faut qu'on soit nombreux je suis
toujours très surpris de voir très
beaucoup beaucoup de monde sur les
départs de course de cyclo-cross chez
les jeunes j'ai vu la dernièrement une
course de Junior où ils étaient 130 au
départ et nous on a du mal à faire des
courses complètes de 24 24 jeunes sur
sur la piste alors que bah il faut aussi
un matériel alors le problème c'est
qu'il faut avoir une piste proche de ses
choix de chez soi et comme on en a pas
assez sur le territoire français c'est
peut-être là il vient la difficulté
c'est ça où vous croyez c'est aussi
peut-être encore l'engouement qui est
pas totalement ancré dans les clubs
cyclistes pour la piste malgré qu'on est
quand même des grands champions non
c'est un manque de structure clairement
si on avait plus de vélo dans le
couverts en France on aurait beaucoup
plus de clubs et de jeunes qui seraient
sur la piste c'est quand même plus
agréable de ce que disait tout à l'heure
d'aller rouler dans un bureau de couvert
que de faire des heures sur route ou
dans la forêt quand il quand il pleut
donc il y a pas de raison et puis
l'engouement il y a des années qu'il
aurait dû qu'il aurait dû naître avec
les résultats de Florian Rousseau
pouvait avoir que Frédéric Magnier
pouvait avoir toutes ces toutes ces
générations qui nous ont apporté des
médailles dans tous les championnats il
y a pas de raison qu'on soit pas plus
nombreux sur sur les vélos on va revenir
justement vous en parler aux membres de
l'équipe de France puisque dans quelques
jours il va y avoir une visite de la
nouvelle soufflerie qu'utilise les
pistards de l'équipe de France je sais
que c'est un sujet qui vous tient
particulièrement à cœur bon c'est une
étape obligatoire maintenant en vue des
Jeux de Rio quand même non
on a déjà parlé pour moi sur sur ce
sujet et je pense que François a perdu
pour nous dire la même chose on a entre
5 et 10 ans de retard les les résultats
qu'on a fait aux Jeux Olympiques il y a
il y a deux ans
une des parties vient de là j'espère que
nos athlètes arriveront à combler à
combler le vide enfin le trou qui était
avec avec les Anglais au jeu au jeu de
Rio c'est vraiment la grosse
interrogation mais mais ouais non il
fallait réagir beaucoup plus tôt est-ce
que vous croyez que ça peut quand même
être utile en vue des championnats du
monde qui vont se dérouler au Vélodrome
national fin février il peut y avoir
déjà du travail bénéfique pour ces
championnats du monde j'en suis sûr ah
non bien sûr de toute façon c'est
quelque chose qu'on avait jamais fait
avant donc même si on le fait que
maintenant et je pense que c'est pas ils
ont pas commencé dernièrement ça date
d'un petit peu fin de l'année dernière
je crois quand Justin Grace était venu
était venu leur les entraîner pendant un
an voilà tout ça se met en place
je suis sûr que de toute façon nos
athlètes seront très compétitifs au
championnats du monde ils sont très
motivés parce que ben ils s'entraîne là
au quotidien et donc bah ça va être leur
piste et ils vont avoir qu'une envie
c'est de briller de briller sur ce sur
ce bel anneau faire raisonner évidemment
la Marseillaise on était un tout petit
peu plus de deux mois de c'est mondiaux
sur piste à 50 ans Yvelines je vous le
rappelle du 18 au 22 février prochain il
y a une étape il y a des étapes de coupe
du monde tout récemment comment vous
voyez à deux mois les les formes on va
dire notamment de François pervers qui
est très attendu sur Simon duos ce
week-end notamment dans le Karine ça a
été un peu compliqué comment vous voyez
ça justement est-ce que c'est inquiétant
parfois de se dire qu'à deux mois il y a
peut-être pas encore tout qui est en
place non pas du tout pour moi ils sont
actuellement en pleine charge
d'entraînement je suis à peu près sûr
qu'ils étaient très fatigués quand ils
sont allés se battre en Angleterre à
Londres
si on regarde les gars qui gagne même
l'anglais je retrouve pas son nom qui en
finale du Karine il fait 6e qui avait
battu Grégory Baugé aux JO il fait 6e il
est complètement inexistant dans le
sprint il arrive pas à se placer ils ont
dans la dernière dans l'avant dernière
ligne droite il laisse tomber il
décroche complètement les deux gars qui
sont en finale de
il y a un hollandais et un Colombien oui
colombien c'est ça je vais pas ouais je
l'ai connaissais pas beaucoup avant donc
non je pense que les gens là enfin les
les athlètes sont vraiment focalisés sur
sur les réseaux sur sur les championnats
du monde enfin février donc pour
l'instant ils sont là pour s'entraîner
et rien d'autre rien d'inquiétant
évidemment cette soufflerie nous vous la
ferons découvrir dans le prochain c'est
fit sport donc lundi prochain merci
beaucoup
d'être passé sur cette histoire
évidemment à très bientôt pour un
nouveau un nouvel avis d'expert on
enchaîne avec le GTC pour vous de cette
édition je vous en parlais dans les
titres ce week-end la ville de Viroflay
a accueilli une compétition inédite sur
le territoire Yvelines la première Coupe
de France de Quidditch vous l'avez bien
entendu inspiré de la saga Harry Potter
la discipline étant en pleine croissance
en France nous notre journaliste Yolaine
Torres SCI est essayé avec des images de
Maxime Lemay
hey vous vous demandez ce que j'ai entre
les gens de bien c'est un balai car nous
allons tester le Quidditch aujourd'hui
mais avant cela les conseils d'un
professionnel
je pouvais vous donner un petit conseil
pour commencer le twitch c'est de ne
jamais oublier qu'on a un balai les
joueurs ont souvent du mal au début à
tenir la balle d'une main et le balai de
l'autre donc ils vont lâcher le ballet
pour saisir la balle le ballet on
partait évidemment et donc c'est une
élimination
et place maintenant à la pratique avec
les super coéquipières on a lu les Harry
Potter on a vu les films du coup ça nous
a donné envie d'aller voir comment
c'était ça elle est amusant
objectif du Quidditch marqué un maximum
de buts en lançant le ballon appelé le
sous à feu dans les cerceaux de l'équipe
adverse c'est la mission de la
poursuivieuse
je suis perdu chacun son rôle il y a
aussi les batteurs eux ils ont les
ballons appelés les Cognards ils doivent
toucher un maximum de joueurs de
l'équipe adverse pour les éliminer le
temps d'un moment
c'est de ma faute
il y a aussi le gardien et enfin
l'attrapeur c'est lui qui doit attraper
le fameux vif d'or accroché dans le dos
d'un des joueurs s'il y arrive son
équipe gagne la partie tout cela bien
sûr sans jamais faire tomber son ballon
on se faisait souvent mais sinon ça
allait super expérience en tout cas pour
cette première il va falloir que je
travaille un petit peu mon physique mon
endurance une adresse un petit peu tout
finalement c'est un sport assez complet
la prochaine fois Anthony c'est toi qui
t'y colle
le rendez-vous est pris à Lyon passe au
JT résultats du résultat pardon du
weekend
et on commence par du basket et ils
l'ont enfin décroché les joueurs de
l'Entente le chêne et Versailles ont
glané leur toute première victoire de la
saison pour le compte de la 11e journée
de National 3 le LCV c'est imposé à
domicile face au dernier Neuville au
bois 81 54 de son côté trap c'est
incliné au Mans 61 53 au classement les
deux équipes restent respectivement 11e
et 7e chez les femmes nationales 2
onzième journée également courte des
fêtes pour les féminines de l'Entente Le
Chesnay Versailles sur le parquet du
5ème grave en champ 68 à 64 football
féminin 8e journée de Division d'Honneur
Montigny retrouve la victoire sur le
terrain dupuc de bus à 1 avec le match
nul du leader vous le voyez Saint-Denis
face à l'équipe réserve de Juvisy les
inné Montaine reviennent tu as deux
points en promotion d'honneur pour le
compte de la sixième journée Élancourt a
enfin décroché sa première victoire de
la saison face à l'Académie 77 5 bus à 2
de son côté Voisins-le-Bretonneux
continue d'être la bonne surprise de ce
début de championnat il s'impose à Paris
trois buts à zéro et vous allez le voir
au classement Poissy est toujours leader
avec 24 points Voisins-le-Bretonneux
cerise sur le podium avec 17 points et
en deuxième partie de tableau et
l'encours fait un bon à la 7e place avec
10 points
Montigny ne perd pas la cadence c'est du
handball lors de la 9e journée de
Nationale de les joueuses de Philippe
letrange recevait le 8e gany à Pierre de
Coubertin et elles ont connu quelques
difficultés malheureusement à entrer
dans le match mener d'un but à la pause
12 à 11 les inimmontaines repassent
devant grâce notamment à 7 buts de Fanny
Jean-Baptiste pour finalement s'imposer
de justesse 20 à 19 les inintènes
conservent leurs deuxième place au
classement à deux longueurs 18h Le Havre
on enchaîne avec du volley-ball et
dixième journée de régional une vous le
voyez Montigny rechute malheureusement
les inhymondins s'inclinators si 3,7 à 0
destin opposé pour plaisir Villepreux
qui s'imposent chez la lanterne rouge
Noisy-le-Grand 3 7 1 Montigny 8e plaisir
quatrième en football américain 4e
journée de Division 3 et la réserve des
Templiers d'Élancourt c'est incliner
face au chevalier d'Orléans 18 à 13 une
dernière info avant de nous quitter
c'est d'une info transfert foutue s
également pour l'équipe justement fanion
des Templiers après l'annonce de
l'arrivée de Zack show un autre
américain va venir renforcer l'effectif
et l'en courtois la personne de Cody red
mond l'Américain de 24 ans va venir
renforcer justement les lignes
défensives de l'équipe c'est la fin de
ce 7 8 sport merci encore une fois de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain mais mieux même heure d'ici là
excellente soirée sur TV filles